oh it's getting worse from Politico New
Hampshire Republicans Feud over bid to
knock Trump off 2024 ballot the state
GOP chair defended Trump's eligibility
on Monday we also have this from Friday
Florida lawyer files challenge to
disqualify Trump from 2024 race citing
14th Amendment now that one hit Friday
we know it has begun they're going to
try and file all these legal challenges
say Trump can't be president but this is
new from Politico take a look at this
New Hampshire Republicans have erupted
in a feud over a long shot effort to
keep former president Donald Trump off
the ballot in 2024 with the chair of the
state GOP insisting Monday the front
runner for the party's nomination will
be included in New Hampshire and
elsewhere some legal Scholars and Trump
critics have long argued the former
president should be disqualified from
the ballot under Section 3 of the 14th
Amendment which bars those who've taken
an oath to support the Constitution from
holding office again if they've quote
engaged in Insurrection against the
United States or given Aid or Comfort to
its enemies but the dispute is taking
off in New Hampshire where Bryant Corky
Messner an attorney who ran on Trump's
endorsement
uh and Senate Namibia blah blah is
questioning Trump's eligibility for the
ballot I'm a constitutional conservative
the words say what they say I quite
frankly believe it isn't Donald Trump's
best interest to get this looked at as
quickly as possible in any effort to
keep Trump off the bat we'll face a
steep climb blah blah blah we get it but
here we go ladies and gentlemen state by
state it's not even 2024 and they're
already trying to remove his name from
the ballot if even a single state
removes Trump's name from the ballot you
will have 75 million people at the bare
minimum saying we never had an election
that yeah I would say that I'm sure you
would say that absolutely I mean 75
million people who voted for him last
time around I can't imagine that they
would consider it a free and fair
election if Trump's name is taken off a
single state Florida especially if if
Trump's name's off in Florida he can't
win especially off especially prior to a
conviction right like he's being found
essentially being found not guilty being
found guilty before a conviction and I I
also think that's why they're trying to
push these things forward is they're not
just looking at the you know gagging him
or the political consequences of it
they're looking at trying to convict him
so that he doesn't even qualify to run
for president but criminal conviction
doesn't matter because the lawsuit
citing the 14th Amendment is a civil
matter it's a political matter
so the question is does a judge think
Trump waged Insurrection we're not here
to you know the judge is going to say
the question laid before the court is
not whether or not Trump committed a
crime but whether or not he waged
Insurrection based on the evidence from
the January 6 committee media report
media report media report right video
video it seems clear the judge says it
just says yes that's it and then it'll
get appealed here's the crazy part
let's just say it's December 12th and it
finally goes to Supreme Court it's
rapidly pushed through and they say we
reject this you cannot remove Trump's
name from the ballot when the election
was a month ago right yeah that's the
concern it's interesting too because and
I'm sure you've seen it the stories out
from the Atlantic New York Times you
know NPR whoever else saying that Trump
should be off the ballot that they
should use this 14th Amendment and then
I was listening to a podcast
um like an NPR Podcast because I'm
always interested to hear what they say
what they say you know and I'll be like
that's not what happened but I'm always
interested to hear it and they were
saying that state like secretaries of
State for each state and Attorneys
General they could make the decision
themselves that Trump was guilty of an
Insurrection and pull his name off the
ballot ballot and they were sort of
encouraging people to do that I will say
though that for the the New Hampshire
thing the New Hampshire GOP chair was on
Charlie Kirk today and was saying that
he talked with the secretary of state
and attorney general and doesn't think
the move against Trump on the ballot is
going to happen but that doesn't mean
that it couldn't happen in other states
and certainly a lot of Democrats are
saying that Attorneys General have the
power to do that what I don't
the Attorney General can unilaterally
just say we take Trump off that's what
they were saying on this podcast I was
listening to today was that they could
that the attorney's General could say
he's guilty of an Insurrection that that
could then be appealed but by that point
like you were saying if he's already off
the ballot then the election
interference has already happened right
right sorry like you have to then
encourage a pencil Campaign which I'm
totally bringing a pencil it won't work
I mean it's going to be an October
surprise right something's gonna happen
they want the legal challenge
to uh to uh to go through
after the after the election yeah that's
right they do it in October uh early
voting and mailing voting is happening
and there's no name there's no Trump on
some of these bouts and you know what
it's entirely possible
based on what we saw in 2020
with the executive unilateral changes to
the election rules and things like that
things like in Pennsylvania where they
did Universal mail and voting in
violation of their own Constitution a
lower court judge said yep then the
Supreme Court goes nah it's probably
fine even though any reasonable person
can be like yeah your Constitution says
you can't do this but they don't care
they're gonna do whatever they want I
wouldn't be surprised if come October
they just as you mentioned Attorneys
General just take Trump Trump's name off
and say there is no question everyone
knows he waged Insurrection we've been
talking about it for years using that
exact word yeah and then you have to use
that word right because they've been
saying Insurrection specifically because
of the Constitution yeah and then what
happens is they say if you have a
problem with Sumi
and everyone does and then the
election's over and they say what's the
big deal we had an election
it's like with covid when in New York
state
um Governor Cuomo shut down all the
churches and a suit was brought and it
ended up getting an emergency hearing
before The Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court said no you can't shut down the
churches but that was months and months
and months later and by that point like
most of the people had stopped going to
church altogether and Cuomo said okay
we'll get rid of it and then he did in
another one in a slightly different way
that did the same thing because it could
then be challenged again and months
later be ruled to yeah look and I don't
think they brought a challenge at that
point I think they were out of cash I
got it I gotta tell you I don't know
when people start to realize that the
courts have no enforcement power
everything's gonna start breaking down
because it's always it's an interesting
thing right the executive branch has its
enforcement power the judicial uh the
legislative branch has subpoena power
and they can make criminal referrals
it's a bit weaker the executive branch
is obviously where most the power is
almost all of it but the uh the courts
what can they do other than bang the
gavel and say do it and of course you
know courts have some degree of
enforcement but it's minimal if a court
says something and no one abide bides it
what do you do I I tell these people
when it comes to private matters too
like you know it's the old sayings a
person can be judgment proof or you
can't get blood out you can't squeeze
blood from a turnip I'm like if you win
a suit against someone like look at Alex
Jones right they sue him for what is it
like the entire GDP of France like no
that's what they requested I think they
won like a billion dollars I'm like
you're not gonna get a penny out of him
because you get in line behind all of
his other uh creditors yeah it's just
you you can't just make these things
happen there's no guarantees
also they're ensuring that he stays on
the air because he's gonna need to stay
in the air in order to earn money to pay
them back oh that's funny too yeah
unless I think they said they want to
destroy him but here's my concern this
is what I was thinking about uh over
this past week
we saw the Chas the chop the George
Floyd
um autonomous Zone we saw the Atlanta
autonomous Zone these things popped up
we saw uh random acts of violence and
now you have on top of the political
violence uh story we'll get to in a
minute a GOP lawyer we don't know what
happened was killed in his home he was
stabbed to death maybe maybe political
maybe not but we'll talk about that but
with the escalation of political
violence that we've been seeing to the
point where Stephen Marsh who wrote the
book the next civil war says we're in
civil strife
at a lingering thought about these
autonomous zones
it's funny to me that uh so I was
trending earlier on Twitter because you
know in your own category right in my
own category too yeah
and it was people people were talking
about Civil War
it's like oh I said it's a drink and I'm
like it's really interesting you know
honest question uh
if I were to tell you that say like a
president claimed the election was
completely fraudulent large amounts of
his supporters were claiming that he
would he's a true president and but it's
illegitimate there had been a dispute
over who actually won the election in
the previous uh election cycle as well
and then you ended up with a bunch of
people storming into the capital and
fighting with police in front you also
had a roving band of 100 100 plus far
left extremists storm onto Government
property in Georgia and in one instance
get into a shootout with police shooting
a cop and then the cops shoot back
killing one of the extremists you have
far left extremists being arrested and
charged overtly with domestic Terror I'm
like at what point do you say maybe yeah
Civil War right my point is this
all of that stuff it's almost like you
got to keep reminding people uh that hey
this stuff happened I don't know where
it goes from here but yeah far left
extremists took over a government site
in Georgia and opened fire on police
after torching several homes in the area
the police came in and returned fire a
cop was struck and one of the extremists
was killed like yo it's getting crazy
all right yeah that is crazy now imagine
this scenario this is what got me
worried
Chaz Chaz and the George Floyd
autonomous Zone were on public property
the Atlanta autonomous Zone was it was
on a Wendy's but the windows was burnt
to the ground and then everyone kind of
abandoned the area
so we have this uh these different
circumstances what happens if far left
extremists occupy a piece of private
land let's say in uh in Georgia or
Tennessee or something slightly more
conservative leaning area near an urban
environment they occupy just at the
autonomous Zone on a derelict piece of
private property the person who owns
that property then goes to the police
and says get these whack jobs off my
property and the police say we have no
capability to do that like we saw with
Chaz and George Floyd and Atlanta the
police backed down and we're like we're
not getting involved but what happens
when a private owner or Corporation says
if the police won't do anything about it
I will well you saw there was a guy in
Atlanta who was he was a landlord he had
he owned a home he was renting it out uh
tenants moved out a couple days later he
went to check on the home and he was met
with a guy with a shotgun a bunch of
dogs and some prostitutes and he was
like oh why are these people in my house
he was like you got to get out of my
house the people in the house the
squatters called the police said that it
was their home the police got the guy
you know carted off it's six months
later he's still waiting for the people
to get out of his house he's still
paying the mortgage and he's stuck he
doesn't have a property he doesn't have
any rights apparently there was also I
mean the other thing too is like it
depends on where the government is do
you Remember The Move Organization in
Philadelphia yeah and they were bombed
actually by the city but this was a
group of black nationalists who had a
taking over a little area in
Philadelphia and West Philadelphia
they had purchased a property in
Virginia and they were planning to move
to Virginia get out of the city and
there was a shooting of an officer
officer ramp I think it was in 79 and a
bunch of people like nine people ended
up getting arrested and put in prison
for that they were called the move nine
um and so they decided to stay and by
staying what ended up happening is the
mayor of Philadelphia who was a black
mayor is it Wilson good am I remembering
that correctly I don't know anyway he uh
coordinated with the FBI and bombed they
fire bombed they fire bombed it and as
people were trying to run out they shot
them yep it was like Waco at a
neighborhood level right yeah and it was
a response to a legitimate issue but
they basically declared war on the
neighborhood yep and they burned down
houses like not just the move compound
but they burned down houses in the area
as well you know that's uh
when the government was more uh had
stronger Monopoly on their violence but
the government was in control of the
violence at that point and that's not
the same now right and so now my concern
is what happens if another Chas happens
but it happens on like
abandoned property not even a band of
derelict is a better way to put it like
someone owns it and they're like let's
say a corporation you know Nordstrom
just shut down in San Francisco which is
like a big deal that is a big deal the
mall is still owned right I think the
the building was uh forfeited by the uh
by Westfield to the bank
so okay
let's say large corporation owns three
acres of of land somewhere and the far
left decides we're going to take it and
no one can stop us
cops aren't going to go engage in a
shootout no they're gonna ignore it not
in an abandoned Mall not even an
abandoned mall like let's imagine it's
just like a an old Warehouse building
that's not being used but it's still on
the books for some big Corporation or
moderately sized Court let's say like
medium local or like Corporation in the
city that's got like a few board members
and maybe a couple hundred employees so
it's small enough but big enough the far
left decides we're gonna take it because
it's not being used it's got broken
windows and graffiti all over but the
people who own it are still keeping
track of it and then what happens when
the police are like
we're not going to do anything not on
city property we're not going to get
involved this is why the Second
Amendment and the right to keep and bear
arms for self-defense is so important
like we've seized over and over again
with Chas and with chop with Uvaldi and
with Parkland like when the police have
mandated that everyone is vulnerable to
violence and that you know they're the
Monopoly on violence they very often
like kind of hang back and in a way you
almost can't blame them because they
also want to get home to their families
but they were holding back parents that
were trying to get in there right in
Uvaldi the guy who actually went in uh
to uh to kill the Uvaldi shooter he was
an off-duty border patrol agent who
ignored their orders not to go in there
and this is the most horrifying story
it's it's horrific and and the case you
were talking about the man in Atlanta he
was trespassed right he was actually
arrested until they realized he was the
property owner it's at some point people
need to realize you are your own first
responder all the old cliche stuff our
parents said about when when seconds
count the police are minutes away
they're they're minutes away to possibly
holds you back as people victimize you
and so we really need to understand just
how Paramount the right to self-defense
is it's sort of terrifying I mean I I
have like tried to avoid interactions
with police my entire life like when I
was a kid at one point there were police
in my in my house and I was like I'm not
gonna repeat this this is never
happening yeah yeah you know but it's
like it's very scary when you come into
contact with police because they show up
and they think everybody is the enemy
head on a swivel yeah
I mean well think about it this way
remember they killed that Australian
lady there was uh so you guys saw that
video where the um was like Extinction
Rebellion people or whatever have the
barricades and and yeah is that by
burning man yeah it was all the people
trying to get to Burning Man and the
climate activists were blocking the road
well the cops apparently got a call that
someone had a gun I guess what happened
was someone told the police you need to
get down here and clear this barricade
before someone shoots one of these
protesters something like that then what
happened is the dispatcher says to the
police there's concerns about a
potential shooting we've got protesters
yeah so then the cops think these
protesters have guns and when the cop
Rams the barricade and jumps out with
his gun he says where's the gun several
times something like that I think that
I'm pretty sure it could be wrong but
think about it from the perspective of
cop all you know is you got a call from
dispatch saying two people are fighting
inside this house it's getting ugly we
need someone to come and shut this down
and then you show up and there's a group
of people in the house being like get
out of our house and some guy that's my
house like what do they do yeah they
typically just say civil matter have a
nice day right like the Tracy Chapman
song the uh the Nevada thing was
absolutely amazing though because you
had climate activists blocking the road
you had Burning Man people trying to get
through the road and then you had Tribal
Police show up yeah to clear the road so
the climate change people think they're
on the side of the Tribal Police they
think that they're on the same side as
them The Burning Man people think
they're on the side of the climate
change people but it turns out they're
not meanwhile the Tribal Police are the
ones who get like all they have all the
oppression points so they're the ones
who get to win and then they show up as
a bunch of guys in trucks with guns
we did have a bunch of upper middle
class white people occupying native land
right and that's one thing they said
you're trespassing on tribal land it's
one thing the cop said to these people
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time